[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le gign les occasions du lion
tu prévient que tu veux je veux
retrouver ma bm cet après midi qui a
compris et bien écoute mon roderick on
n'a pas grand chose pour le moment à
part ce joli petit carnet et la
réceptionniste
mais elle nous dit qu'elle n'a
absolument rien vu du tout j'ai
absolument rien vu du tout qu'elle a
beau celle ci est lenovo non non mais
laisse tomber délicat elles sont
payables comptant quelque harb a fait
chauffer la vidéosurveillance à d'erika
je vais voir qui m'a volé ma bm que
zarma je roule avec la citroën de merde
de jürgen moi j'en suis très content
regarde le mois 6 babolat mais moi ce
que je suis en forme et moi le papier
guidée au parquet je te prie de
m'excuser amérique mais je crois que
j'ai enregistré téléfoot sur des bombes
j'en peux plus de toit entre arrête de
me regarder sur ma vie je vais te casser
un bras arrête de regarder chômage et la
prennent indique la bm est ici sa mère
c'est fermé tiens tiens moi ça j'ai
trouvé ça par terre je ferrais soir à ta
mère parce que je trouve ta peau pour
attaquer pas c'est pas grillage qui va
l'arrêter américain en plus jean pleine
bourre en ce moment j'ai atteint mon
poids de forme
l'asthme et terrier or le fait me serra
poli bird art donc qu'est-ce qu'ils font
mon père sa mère chauffer l'air de rien
je me suis dit que non j'ai encore
trouvé walo centraide me casser les
glaoui saper tout de suite yoplait tu
dois être en train de courir partout
pour retrouver la bm celui-là
sapristi je m'appelle à l'eau si nous au
cdj rien trouvé vous en êtes où il se
fait deux jours qu'on l'a retrouvé ta
voiture d'eric charrier a laissé une
aussi des rites la poussée pour
l'économie comme inspecteur bonjour est
ce que tu es et sagement faut beau
gerard et léo la baie on dirait que ta
voiture et là bas
cette chute nama bmc kata sepa childéric
intérieur tout en cuir bourghelles tu as
fait tout de suite aimé ma ah bah ouais
zéro tracas zéro blabla
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]